qui
[Musique]
frédéric et béatrice sont accueillis
charte il ya un mois
shaft n'est pas un chien comme les
autres c'est un futur chien d'assistance
attention il ne faut pas les confondre
avec les chiens guides d'aveuglés pour
moi l'assistance froid et c'étaient des
chiens guides aveugles donc il a fallu
déjà comprendre que le chien
d'assistance c'est une autre forme
d'assistance notre faim avec des formes
variées d'ailleurs puisque ça peut être
pour des handicaps moteur ça peut être
là la détection de crises d'épilepsie ça
peut être
l'accompagnement d'enfants hyperactifs
ou autiste pour devenir des chiens
d'assistance ces animaux doivent être
formés d'abord dans des familles
d'accueil c'est le cas de frédéric et
béatrice ils ont reçu shaft un chiot
golden retriever en juin pendant 16 mois
ces deux illinois vont les levées selon
des règles strictes
on jette pas bonne
on ne peut pas le laisser mordiller non
plus il faut pas sauter sur nous pour
l'alimentation
on ne lui met pas ses croquettes dans
une gamelle on lui éparpiller les
croquettes sur le sol dans la maison ou
à l'extérieur imaginez une personne en
situation de fragilité qui ne peut pas
forcément se baisser pour mettre les
croquettes dans une gamelle
voilà qui peut juste et les donner au
chien à la main derrière chaque commande
c'est pas formaté le chien pour le
formater j'ai vraiment le préparer à sa
prochaine vie pour qu'ils soient le
moins perturbée possible tous les soirs
ces séances de dressage pour shaft
[Musique]
élever un chien d'assistance signifie
aussi pouvoir l'emmener partout
habillé de sa cape bleue et jaune shaft
se rend au supermarché pour la première
fois c'est pas mal à il est un petit peu
déconcentré mais il n'est pas stressé
par le bruit des réfrigérateurs c'est un
environnement qui est nouveau pour lui
s'en sort bien dans sa prochaine vie de
chien d'assistance shaft devrait être en
capacité d'aller partout avec son maître
magasin musée mairie tous les lieux
habituellement interdit aux chiens lui
sont ouverts mais parfois ce n'est pas
si simple leila premier réflexe c'est un
chien donc on est dans un lieu interdit
aux chiens donc ça demande une
négociation
qui peut compliquer il a fallu que je
sors sur mon téléphone le texte de loi
qui stipule l'article de la loi de 88
qui stipule que ce chien à la fois quand
il sera un chien d'assistance et pendant
sa formation il est accueilli accepté
dans tous les lieux publics dans tous
les transports pour frédéric ces sorties
sont aussi l'occasion de faire parler de
l'association handi'chiens dans les
yvelines une délégation vient juste de
s'ouvrir elle est composé de quatre
familles d'accueil qui se réunissent
tous les 110
[Musique]
c'est l'occasion pour les familles de
faire un point sur l'évolution du chien
avec les délégués faire des exercices
mais aussi et surtout de créer une
grande famille handi'chiens abbas est
fondamentale puisque on fait tous les
réglages dans son éducation en fonction
des consignes qu'ils nous sont donnés
par les délégués et puis on peut voir
aussi comment progresse les autres
chiens donc c'est important de faire ces
petits points nous en tant qu' en tant
que bénévole et il est délégué on
encadre donc un groupe de familles
d'accueil qui peut aller de trois à six
familles d'accueil et on aide à
l'éducation pendant 16 mois de ces
petits chiens c'est un groupe c'est une
aventure d'animaux mais aussi c'est une
aventure humaine pendant seize mois le
groupe est ensemble on travaille
ensemble on s'amuse ensemble on rigole
ensemble des fois on pleure ensemble
parce que c'est difficile mais on sait
aussi une aventure c'est une aventure
humaine et c'est vraiment très très
agréable et on s'épaule les uns les
autres l'information vient juste de
débuter pour ce groupe de chiens dans
les yvelines dans plusieurs mois ils
seront remis à ce que l'on appelle les
bénéficiaires chaque jour c'est près de
15000 personnes qui reçoivent l'aide
d'un chien d'assistance au quotidien en
france
[Musique]